In death penalty cases.
In any criminal case,
one of the most critical procedures is the selection of the jury.
Of course,
first jurors are asked questions to see if there's anything they know about the
case that would keep them from being fair and impartial or any reason that would
keep them from being fair and impartial.
And once a group of jurors has been selected,
uh,
who supposedly can be fair and impartial,
each side exercises what are called peremptory strikes.
Also discretionary strikes,
the number that each side has depends upon the state in which the case is tried.
And the state law,
one of the longstanding problems,
so peremptory strikes is that they've been used to exclude people of Color,
African Americans in particular from jury service.
We want to talk about that today with [inaudible] who was a graduate of Yale law
school and who since 2008,
uh,
has been at the equal justice institute,
of Alabama and has been dealing with this issue,
uh,
all the time.
See a thank you for coming.
Thank you so much for having me.
First thing I'd like for you to do is just talk about Alabama and why juries and
who's on the jury might be important and Alabama.
Sure,
absolutely.
So,
um,
in Alabama,
uh,
unlike sort of the trend that you see nationally where death sentencing is going
down,
Alabama beat the opposite is true.
They have extremely high death sentencing rate,
the highest per capita of any state in the country.
And in 2008 the year I started at Eji,
Alabama,
which has a population of around 4 million people sentenced more people to death
in raw numbers than Texas,
which has a population of over 23 million.
And you know,
when I talk to people about this,
they sort of ask why,
you know,
why does Alabama have this rate that's so high?
And I think I just like to highlight three reasons before talking about jury
selection in the state.
Um,
so the first reason I think that Alabama's death sensing rate is so high is the
poor quality of defense lawyers and there's no statewide public defender system.
Um,
and they're,
the state relies solely on a sort of court appointed system of lawyers,
which means the judges have a list of lawyers who are available and they just
call on those people who may have some but may have really no background in
trying a capitol case.
So that's a major problem.
The second is a really unique feature of Alabama's death penalty,
a law which is judge override.
So in Alabama,
a jury can give a life verdict in a death penalty case.
They can sentence the defendant to life and a judge who's elected in the state
can set aside that verdict and overturn it simply because he or she disagrees
with the jury finding.
Um,
and then the third reason,
I think the Justice Sotomayor recently pointed out that those overrides are
often politically motivated.
Absolutely.
I think you see,
so 2008 is a perfect example of that.
The statistics that I started out with,
that was an election year.
Um,
a lot of judges who were running for reelection and there've been,
you know,
quite extensive findings that in election years,
more judges as they're running for reelection override in capital cases because
they feel political pressure to do so.
Um,
and so right now it's not an insignificant number.
You know,
there's around 200 people on Alabama's death row.
Approximately 23% of those people on the death row now are there because of a
judge override.
So those are people who got life sentences from a jury,
but nevertheless are on death row because a judge overturned that verdict and
sentence them to death.
And then just the third reason,
which is particularly relevant to today's topic is racial bias.
And I just want to highlight a few features of Alabama system in this respect.
So the first is that of the 19 appellate judges in Alabama on the civil
appellate court,
the criminal appellate court,
and the Supreme Court,
none are people of color.
All of those judges are white.
Um,
which is unusual in a state that has a significant African American population
as Alabama does.
Um,
the second is that the overwhelming majority of elected trial judges in the
state,
um,
are white.
And then finally there,
there are elected prosecutors,
district attorneys in each of Alabama's counties.
And so of the 42 elected prosecutors in the state,
only one is African American.
So when you zoom out and look at this,
what you see is a judicial system where almost all of the actors are white and
none of them are people of color.
And given this backdrop,
the jury becomes really significant as the one place in these courtrooms where
African American voices could be heard.
Um,
and so it's something that we pay a lot of attention to in the cases at Eji that
we take is to make sure and try and ensure that African American voices are
being heard through the jury process,
especially against this backdrop where that's the only way their voices will
come in.
And yet what we've seen in Alabama is that even with this supreme court case,
Batson versus Kentucky in 1986 that outlawed racial discrimination in jury
selection.
Prosecutors are still routinely using their peremptory strikes,
their discretionary strikes to remove jurors from jury service because they're
African American.
Um,
and just one dramatic example of that is a case that we litigated called
[inaudible] where the prosecutor in that case in Dallas County,
which is about 55% African American,
the prosecutor in that case eliminated 23 of 23 African American jurors who are
eligible service.
And the defense lawyer in that case raise an objection and asked the prosecutor
to explain to the court why he was removing all of these African Americans.
And the prosecutors exam explanation was that they appeared to be of low
intelligence.
Um,
that was his purported race neutral reason for removing these jurors.
And the trial judge presiding over that case accepted that as fine.
Um,
and this capital defendant went to trial before an all white jury in a county
that's more than half African American and was sentenced to death.
And that's just an example of a case that Eji takes where despite this law and
despite a very large population of eligible jurors,
nevertheless,
we're seeing capital trials where people of color are going to trial before an
all white jury.
Let's back up just a minute and talk about that Supreme Court decision.
A lot of people say or think that there's no longer race discrimination and
selecting jurors by,
by these use of peremptory strikes.
But,
but how exactly,
just explain how exactly the bats and process works.
But in the case of course is Batson versus Kentucky,
a Supreme Court decision that dealt with,
uh,
an old Alabama case,
actually a,
that had allowed,
uh,
prosecutors to structures for any reason,
race,
religion,
or any other reason that they might have the supreme court.
1986 said no,
but what was the remedy?
Right?
So what Batson sets out is a three step process that Judd trial judges have to
apply.
And the holding of Batson is that you cannot discriminate.
You cannot remove a juror because of race,
but you can remove a juror if you can provide the court with what's called a
wrist neutral reason.
So there are other valid reasons to remove a juror other than their race.
Um,
and how this is applied in the courts is that jury selection begins.
The prosecutor is using his or her strikes and removes,
let's say five eligible African Americans in a row.
The defense lawyer then bears the burden of objecting to what's happening and
putting the court on notice.
Um,
so the defense lawyer would say,
I object under Batson versus Kentucky.
The prosecutor is striking five African American jurors at that point.
If the judge finds what's called a prime aphasia case of discrimination.
So some minimal evidence that discrimination might be going on,
um,
the burden,
there's a disparate use,
right?
If they're striking far more African American jurors than white jurors,
even though African Americans,
as you said in the mcgehee case where a minority,
uh,
but the prosecution used every single strike in that case against African
Americans.
Right?
Exactly.
So it led,
made out a pretty clear prime,
a Fisher case
be a strong prima facia case,
but the language of the court,
um,
and how it's been applied to something we can debate,
but in theory it's supposed to be a relatively low bar that the defense lawyer
has to meet.
And so if there's something going on that seemed suspicious to the defense
lawyer,
he or she can object and then the trial judge will,
the burden will shift to the prosecutor if the trial judge finds a prima facia
case.
And then at that point we moved to baton step two where the burden shifts to the
prosecutor who then has to account for these strikes and explain why they are
not the result of racial discrimination.
And he or she does that by providing race neutral reasons for each strike.
Um,
so you would have to have an explanation for why you struck juror number five.
That is not,
I struck the stir because they're African American.
You could say,
I struck this juror because this juror is a school teacher and there's some
theory of my case that makes me think that's a valid reason to use the strike.
Um,
and then the trial judge then would evaluate these reasons that the prosecutor
has given and you either accept them or reject them as,
um,
as pretext jewel and not,
you know,
not reasons that sort of meet the burden and justify the use of the strikes.
And if that is the case,
then the,
the,
the judge will find that the Batson case has been violated and can,
you know,
call back that juror who was struck.
And you were saying it's three steps because the prosecutor gives the reason.
And then at the third step,
the judge weighs all the evidence,
whatever it may be,
all the circumstances,
how many strikes were used,
how disproportionate was,
how PauseAble the reasons are and decides whether there's race discrimination.
Right?
But even in a case where 23 out of 23 were used against African Americans to get
an all white jury and a majority Black County,
the judge upheld all 23 reasons.
I want to ask you about this.
Thurgood Marshall said when,
when Bateson was decided that any prosecutor would be able to think up reasons,
uh,
for striking African Americans,
do you see that that's come true?
Did he I
predict that correctly.
I think that's absolutely true.
I think that prosecutors have to do very little.
They have to basically say something of that's that's minimally acceptable and
they will not be found to have violated Batson.
But I would even go further than that and use the mcgehee case as an example of
this.
So not only did the trial judge in that case with where there were 23 out of 23
strikes and the reason was there appeared to be of low intelligence,
not only did the trial judge accept that as a reason that case was litigated
through every state court in Alabama and every state court in Alabama found no
bats in violation.
And it only when the equal justice initiative had that case in the 11th Circuit
Court of Appeals,
that it was reversed.
And that's significant because I think not only do you see trial judges
accepting reasons that really don't pass muster when you,
when you think about them carefully,
but appellate courts who are reviewing these cases on appeal often either except
reasons that are,
you know,
don't really assume justifiable or they invent reasons after the fact that the
prosecutor could have used the strike.
So they might look at a case where the prosecutor hasn't given any reasons but
say,
well,
maybe it could have been for this reason or that reason and supply some
reasoning and then affirm the case.
And that's what happened in the gay.
He,
they,
these are sort of looked at the case and said,
well,
there could have been some other reasons and kept the case,
uh,
moving and,
and didn't reverse it.
And so I think you have the prosecutors,
the trial judge's and the appellate courts all kind of together are part of the
problem of why Batson isn't meaningful in practice in the states where I,
where I work.
Well and then mega he,
you had this overwhelming case.
So it finally gets to the very last federal court.
The trial court upheld the reasons the Alabama Court of criminal appeals,
the Supreme Court,
the Federal District Court upheld the reason.
Yeah.
So it was only when it got to the very last stage of the process that this
overwhelming case was found and the reasons were found to be quite suspicious
because the low intelligence in particular reason that was given.
But what about in a case where you don't have such an incredibly overwhelming
case?
What do we see happening in those cases?
Right.
I think that's a great question because Miguel,
he is the rare case where you have the prosecutor on the record first.
It's rare because the defense lawyer made an objection so often there's just no
objection.
So the courts never put on notice and doesn't Sua sponte get involved?
And so we gay,
he's rare because the defense lawyer said something which required the
prosecutor to respond.
Um,
and then your first point when we first started talking,
you,
you're talking about the quality of defense lawyers.
So if you have a poor defense lawyer who doesn't,
maybe it's never heard of the Batson case,
this will never be raised.
It will never be raised.
And the problem with that is that you lose the most critical opportunity,
which is in the courtroom while jury selection is happening to force the
prosecutor to right then and there give their best reasons,
um,
if they have any.
And when you don't have that,
what happens is even if we are able years later as appellate lawyers to take the
case and send it back down,
the problem is years pass and the prosecutors can have a really long time to
come up with reasons after the fact that these strikes were used.
So we've had that where the defense lawyer maybe didn't know about Batson even
though it's been in effect for,
you know,
now,
since 1986 so a long time.
Um,
and when the case,
when we get the case in,
raise something and it's sent back the prosecutors write briefs explaining,
well maybe this person had a traffic citation.
And that's why I struck them.
And it's just a lot harder to engage in a meaningful and truthful back and forth
about why these strikes were used.
If it's not raised right then and there in the courtroom during jury selection.
And even now in 2014 we see all too many cases where there's no bats in a
violation raised by the defense lawyer at trial.
And it's,
it's a major problem both because you lose that reason and because on appeal
you're going to be held to a much higher standard of review if there was not an
objection.
Right.
And often the appellate court is going to say the issue's waved.
Did it can't be heard at all because there was an objection.
Absolutely.
It's really only in
death penalty cases where you might be able to get around that.
Um,
but even in those cases you're going to be held to a much higher standard if the
defense lawyer didn't object.
But in most cases,
if the defense lawyer doesn't object and most criminal cases,
that issue is gone forever.
So no,
it could be,
you know,
25 out of 25 strikes if the defense lawyer doesn't object and it's not a death
penalty case,
no matter how compelling the bats in violation is.
Um,
there's really,
there's nothing you can do
on appeal and there must,
there are also some psychological things going on here,
right.
Then dynamics in play,
because it may depend on the relationship between the defense lawyer and the
prosecutor and the prosecutor and the judge in terms of what you're claiming in
a Batson objection.
Is that the prosecution intentionally discriminated on the basis of race.
There's no getting around that it's intentional,
am I right?
Racial discrimination and that the reasons given our pretextual and other words
that the prosecutor is lie about the reasons I would think often judges and
prosecutors who work together on case after case,
that's going to be very hard finding,
isn't it for a judge to ways.
It certainly is.
And we've been,
you know,
in trainings and in meetings with defense lawyers if we're,
looking at the cases on appeal and they'll say that,
um,
you know,
we'll talk to defense lawyers who will say,
I'm just not comfortable accusing this guy who I'm going to see at church or in
the grocery store of deliberately
know discriminating on the basis of race.
And we have to explain that no matter how uncomfortable it may feel,
your client has a right to a jury that is,
you know,
the product of a fair jury selection process and it's your job to raise the
claim.
Um,
if you see evidence of discrimination.
But I think especially in small counties where there is,
uh,
you know,
long standing relationships with the prosecutor and with the judge,
um,
people have a hard time raising Batson.
So some defense lawyers have never heard of it,
but I'd say an equal,
if not greater number have heard of the case.
But just find it uncomfortable to make a Batson objection in court because of
the reasons that you,
that you kind of pointed to.
And I just want to ask is 27 strikes?
It's an awful lot of strikes in a case.
Uh,
does Alabama have a system which gives people more strikes than you would have?
Like in Georgia for example,
each side gets 10 strikes in Virginia,
each side gets just three strikes.
So Alabama,
that's a lot of strikes.
Yeah.
Alabama has a unique system.
We have unlimited peremptory strikes,
which means that,
um,
there's no sort of set number of strikes that either side has going in.
And that's why you see these cases with sometimes very large numbers like 23 out
of 23 strikes.
And some courts in Alabama and other states have expressed concern about this.
The Mississippi Supreme Court,
um,
in a Batson case,
you know,
in the last 10 years or so,
express concern about peremptories and sort of threatened to eliminate them
altogether because they're discrimination is still so rampant.
And I think courts where they're effective trial and appellate lawyers are
seeing evidence of this.
But we as,
as lawyers representing,
uh,
people in capital cases became interested in sort of documenting this,
um,
as a phenomenon beyond the individual cases we were working on and have done a
lot of research into sort of discrimination in jury selection in the south and
found unfortunately,
that this is something that is really widespread in Alabama and in other
southern states particularly.
And what did you find,
tell us about your findings.
So in,
uh,
in 2009,
Eji began a sort of year and a half long project to research and document a jury
selection practices in southern states.
And we looked at Arkansas,
Alabama,
uh,
Louisiana,
South Carolina,
Tennessee,
Florida,
um,
and Georgia.
And we looked at what was going on and whether,
you know,
25 years after Bateson was Batson working,
was it doing what the Supreme Court intended it to do,
which was prevent people from discriminating against African Americans and other
racial minorities in jury selection.
And what we found was really distressing,
which was that this discrimination continues,
um,
and it continues in quite dramatic fashion.
And we sort of,
we found,
just to give you a few examples,
we found a county in Alabama where nearly 80% of African Americans qualified for
jury service has been eliminated from participating.
And we found majority black counties where it was routine for people to go to
trial and face the death penalty in front of all white juries despite the fact
that the counties were majority African American.
Um,
and we found to me one of the parts that was most kind of moving and interesting
was that we went and talked to the jurors themselves.
So the people who had been called for jury service and then sent home on or
excluded because of a reason that a court leader found was discrimination.
And so these are people who have been,
courts in America have found we're intentionally discriminated against by a
prosecutor.
And for me it was just fascinating to talk to these folks and hear from them
what their experiences were like.
And it was really moving.
I mean,
I remember meeting a woman in Mississippi who'd lived through the civil rights
movement,
um,
who fought for the right to vote,
who had been called for jury service and then who'd been sent home for no reason
at all.
And so when she spoke to me about it,
she's,
she became emotional talking about how much being an American meant to her and
how much the right to vote and the right to be a full citizen meant to her.
And she really grew emotional recalling the sting of humiliation of being in
that courtroom and being sent home and not being able to do anything about it.
Um,
and let me just so we're clear on this,
she was sent home because the prosecutor used a peremptory strike to remove her.
Yes.
And then gave her a reason to the judge who upheld that reason so that it was
race neutral,
but there were a lot of other African Americans who were being sent home for the
same reason.
Right,
right.
And are these reasons,
are they any sort of protection to people like this woman that you saw or our
trial judges and state appellate courts upholding these reasons in most cases,
cases there they're being upheld.
I mean we've,
we've,
just to give you some examples,
we've seen people dismissed because they're too old at 43 or two young at 28.
Um,
because they wore eyeglasses because of the way they walked because they were
single.
They were married,
they were divorced because they lived in a predominantly black neighborhood.
That's something that we've seen frequently upheld by appellate courts because
they attended a historically black college.
Um,
I mean these are reasons that prosecutors give in open court to justify using
these strikes.
And what was stunning to me was to talk to these jurors who explained how
painful it was,
um,
to go through this because I think people think of jury service sometimes as an
obligation.
Um,
and even folks who have a lot of other things to do with their lives took it
seriously.
The fact that they were called to court and asked to participate in the process
and they knew what was going on,
um,
when they were sent home.
And it's interesting cause jury selection is unique in that the supreme court
has said that when intentional discrimination in jury selection occurs,
it's not just the rights of the defendant who are affected.
It's the rights of the structure as well.
That juror has a right to sit on the jury and participate fully in their civic
duty.
And so the discrimination impacts them as well.
And so I just couldn't have found that to be more true when I spoke to people.
I remember one woman I talked to was dismissed because the prosecutor said she
belongs to a family that is a criminal family,
um,
in this county and that they engage in crime.
And she was humiliated by this.
There were people in court in her community who she knows she's never had
problems with the law.
Her kids are,
um,
are good kids.
Her husband has never been in trouble with law enforcement.
This had happened years before and she said she still remembers this and is
angry about it and felt really humiliated that the prosecutor was allowed to say
that about her.
Um,
and get away with it.
And I think that's another,
uh,
something else we discovered both from talking to the jurors themselves and from
our research is that there really isn't prosecutorial accountability.
Even when in the rare case like the [inaudible] case,
you find dramatic evidence,
there isn't accountability for prosecutors.
Um,
so what happened in [inaudible] when this court found discrimination is that
they reversed the case and he is entitled to a new trial because of that.
But nothing happens to the prosecutor.
There's no discipline,
there's no sanction,
they're not removed,
they're not monitored.
Um,
and that in our opinion is sort of a big problem that recurs in a lot of these
cases because you see the same offices doing the same thing over and over again.
And first it's hard to catch them doing it.
But even if you do,
it's very hard to use that finding to prevent future problems with jury
selection.
And one thing we should just mention is that once a trial judge a pulses reasons
than all the courts that look at it after that give a great deal of it
deference to the trial judge.
Right?
It's absolutely true.
So once a trial judge agrees and finds there is no discrimination,
not only,
um,
do you have the problem of sort of trying to get the prosecutor to explain what
they did when the trial judge said they didn't have to the ones that travelers
has upheld what the,
what happened at trial?
The appellate court will absolutely defer to what the trial judge did and they
will only disrupt the trial judge's findings if there's really overwhelming
evidence.
And the [inaudible] case was that rare example of overwhelming evidence that's
so extreme and so extraordinary.
The 11 circuit called it astonishing in its opinion that it got the court to
revisit what the trial judge had done and overturn it.
But that's a very,
very high burden to meet on appeal.
And,
and we shoot this,
he cases,
uh,
is a really aberrational case that in most cases,
in fact,
I think not long after that,
the 11th circuit had a case called [inaudible] versus commissioner where over 20
strikes had been used against African Americans,
basically every strike and the court upheld and it was upheld all the way
through the Alabama courts and the federal courts.
But of course the more typical cases where maybe eight strikes are used against
the eight African Americans and the jury pool.
And those are normally upheld or are they not?
They are.
And I would just also add that often you don't need 23 strikes because African
Americans are being limited from jury selection in other ways,
um,
through the way that the jury pool is selected.
So in counties there the,
we call these under-representation problems.
So there could be problems like they use voting list or driver's license,
or there's,
there's certain ways of selecting juries that counties can employ that will lead
to fewer African Americans ever being called for jury service in the first
place.
Um,
and those are what we call under-representation problems.
So what I see in a lot of Alabama cases is that even in counties with a very
substantial African American population,
you might see a jury pool in which out of a hundred people there are only four
people called for jury service who are African American.
In a case like that,
the prosecutor doesn't need 23 strikes to remove them,
right?
He or she only needs to use a couple and it's,
you know,
you come up with a few reasons and then there's really very little,
we can do 'em on appeal.
And I think that is a perfect example of why Mckay,
he really is the rare case because often it's four or five strikes and the
courts will just defer to what the prosecutor did.
So eji several years ago filed the lawsuit addressing these under-representation
problems because there are African Americans in every county who've never been
called for jury service.
And so it's rare to have a situation where you have that many people in the
pool.
Um,
and then the prosecutor strikes all of them.
And then the prosecutor gives basically a,
a pretty outrageous region on the record.
Um,
that's,
that's a unique situation.
So,
yeah,
and as a general rule,
the prosecutors strikes are not aggregated where we look from case to case to
case.
I know in North Carolina they put together all the strikes and death penalty
cases of jurors and it was profound in terms of how a out of balance it was that
African American jurors were being struck so much more,
uh,
than white jurors.
But,
and your lawsuit,
you actually looked at one jurisdiction in Alabama.
We did.
So we,
Houston County,
Alabama,
which is a county with a very high capital sentencing rate,
a large African American population,
yet we're almost,
every death penalty case is tried before an all white or nearly all white jury.
Um,
and that was the basis of the lawsuit.
And I think what,
um,
what you see in a lot of these cases is there really isn't any mechanism for
looking from case to case to case except we can allege as in support of our
discrimination,
we can urge the court to look back at previous findings of discrimination or at
um,
the extent to which these strikes are used.
So there are ways we can try to get that in.
But I think one of the problems with the way Batson works now is that there
isn't a mechanism for that.
And so in this report that Eji did,
we urge people in communities to,
you know,
go into their courtrooms in their local towns and cities and watch what's
happening in jury selection and document and monitor what the courts are doing
and,
and publicizes as we're trying to do in our community in Alabama because the,
um,
one of the biggest challenges is that,
you know,
this stuff happens behind closed doors,
often in small courtrooms where there aren't people watching and documenting
what's going on.
And the results I think kind of speak for themselves.
Thurgood Marshall said in his pain and bats and the only solution was to
eliminate peremptory strikes.
Was He right?
I,
I'm not sure he was right,
but I think it's certainly if things continue the way they,
they have been,
I think he will be proven.
Right.
Um,
I think the only way to kind of write the ship is to do several different things
to improve accountability.
And the reason I'm inclined to think Thurgood Marshall might be right is that I
haven't seen much evidence of a commitment to doing the things we need to do to
improve accountability and to eliminate racial discrimination.
And I think training defense lawyers as part of this,
I think I'm holding prosecutors accountable is a big part of it.
I also think that,
um,
there are,
there are procedural bars which are employed that you kind of alluded to
earlier,
that there are lots of technical reasons that make it hard for harder to prove
discrimination and to get courts to do something about it,
even if you do prove it.
So there are people who have been executed,
um,
despite overwhelming evidence that their jury was illegally selected.
And that's because we have these procedural bars that allow courts to say,
oh,
this is a very valid claim,
but it's too late.
You should have raised it earlier at trial and sorry,
there's nothing we can do.
And with that kind of attitude towards something as fundamental as having a fair
jury of your peers decide whether you live or die,
it's hard to see,
um,
that were sort of making progress towards the aspiration of bats and becoming a
reality for people who go to trial.
Well,
thank you very much for talking to us.
I mean,
what we see is that people who for years were not allowed to vote and therefore
weren't on the voter or the journalists at all.
Now they're on the juror list,
but they continue to be struck.
So as you said about the people you talked to in the study,
uh,
they're still going home without serving as jurors,
even though technically,
legally they're to be.
But because of these practices,
we're still seeing,
even in the deep south,
even in the states,
the old confederacy with very substantial African American populations,
we're still seeing death pi cases tried to all white juries.
Yes.
And I think that's,
that's something we see routinely,
unfortunately.
Well,
thank you again for being willing.